this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman I'm here
with the IMDB interviewing people so
you're on a boat [ __ ] right on
top of a boat and [ __ ] interviewing
people meeting [ __ ] famous people and
stuff like that meeting my betters it
was really cool
I interviewed Jamie Lee Curtis which was
a [ __ ] trip I've loved her since like
you know of course Halloween I was a kid
we grew up with her as a scream queen
all those horror movies and so so she
was phenomenal did she like came on the
boat in acting for like 40 years very
funny lady very funny lady and takes
[ __ ] charge man like just gets on the
boat and we start the interview and you
know you could tell she's unfamiliar
with my brand of whimsy and [ __ ] so
she's not waiting for me to like control
the interview boom she just starts it
laying down the law which it's gonna be
so I am right away I was like you know
give it up for the for the once and
future and forever scream green the
Queen Jamie Lee Curtis and everyone's
applauding [ __ ] and so she just knows
what to do you got you forget like maybe
maybe you don't she was a Fish Called
Wanda she's [ __ ] legit funny knows
what she's done so she goes like this
and she makes me kiss her [ __ ] hand
which I did but she was an absolute
delight man to speak to at one point
though I [ __ ] like I said we were
talking about Halloween and I referenced
Michael Myers as the shape which is
something in John Carpenter wrote in the
script and stuff and if you know that
movie and you're a fan of it like some
people call Michael Myers but like if
you're deep cuts you call him the shape
right so one point I was saying blah
blah blah the shape and she goes you are
a think that's the moment I've melted
her heart a little bit and then as she
was leaving she was like you have to
cast me I was like I will and I won't
even have you killed at the end like
that movie character reboot
holy [ __ ] you are absolutely right there
oh my god there's a role of a judge it
plays for like [ __ ] one scene but I
was like it's a lady judge and I was
like who could it be
you [ __ ] her
brilliant idea man excellent job you're
welcome
casting by Hrothgar
[Music]
you
[Music]